THAT'S WHY WE'RE-- OH, BY THE
WAY, THAT'S WHY WE ARE SO
EXCITED TO ANNOUNCE THE START OF
OUR 2016 ELECTION COVERAGE.
( LAUGHTER )
>> Larry: THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU GOT IT.
( APPLAUSE )
THAT'S RIGHT.
( CHEERS )
"BACKLASH 2016: THE
UNBLACKENING" BEGINS TONIGHT.
IT IS TIME FOR AMERICA TO SAY
( BLEEP ) YOU TO THE NOTION THAT
ONCE YOU GO BLACK YOU NEVER GO
BACK.
( LAUGHTER )
SO HOW DID MR. CRUZ ANNOUNCE HIS
MISSION IMPOSSIBLE RUN FOR
PRESIDENT?
>> RIGHT AROUND MIDNIGHT,
CONSERVATIVE FIRE BRAND TED CRUZ
TWEETED OUT THIS ANNOUNCEMENT.
"I'M RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT."
>> Larry: I'M SORRY, DID SHE
SAY TWEETED AND AROUND MIDNIGHT?
IS TED CRUZ TRYING TO WIN
HASHTAG WARS?
( LAUGHTER )
PRESIDENTIAL ANNOUNCEMENTDON'T
HAPPEN AT MIDNIGHT.
BOOTY CALLS HAPPEN AT MIDNIGHT,
ALL RIGHT.
AND OTHER THAN THE BACKSEAT OF
YOUR HUNDAI ELANTRA, THERE'S NO
BETTER PLACE TO HOOK UP THAN AT
A COLLEGE.
>> WE'RE HERE AT LIBERTY
UNIVERSITY BECAUSE THERE'S A
BUILT-IN AUDIENCE FOR EXACTLY
WHO SENATOR CRUZ WANTS TO REACH.
IT IS 10,000 YOUNG EVANGELICAL
CHRISTIANS.
>> Larry: OH, AND BY THE WAY,
THERE'S NO BETTER PLACE TO START
THE UNBLACKENING OF THE
PRESIDENCY THAN AT A UNIVERSITY
IN LYNCHBURG, VIRGINIA.
( LAUGHTER )
NO, BUT I'VE GOT TO GIVE CRUZ
CREDIT.
10,000 KIDS.
SERIOUSLY.
BIG NUMBERS THERE.
HE HAS OBVIOUSLY TAPPED INTO THE
YOUTH CULTURE.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
WE'RE REQUIRED TO GO TO
THESE CONVOCATION SERVICES OR
ELSE WE ARE FINED $10.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE ).
>> Larry: THAT'S LIKE SETTING
UP YOUR OWN SURPRISE PARTY,
RIGHT.
YOU GUYS!
I'M SO SURPRISED!
WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE?
WHERE'S DOUG?
ALL RIGHT, SOMEBODY'S GETTING
FINED $10.
ALL RIGHT, SO LET'S HEAR WHAT
CAPTAIN FAKE CROWD HAD TO SAY.
>> A PRESIDENT WHO STANDS
UNAPOLOGETICALLY WITH THE NATION
OF ISRAEL.
SECURES THE BORDERS.
REPEALS OBAMACARE.
LIBERTY.
SMALL BUSINESSS.
ABOLISHING THE I.R.S.
>> Larry: YEAH.
WHO NEEDS THE I.R.S.
BLOW THAT THING UP.
>> WHOOO!
>> Larry: WHOO-HOO.
YEAH, BABY, GOOD-BYE TAXES.
YEAH, WHAT ELSE WE DOING?
>> IMAGINE A SIMPLE FLAT TAX.
( APPLAUSE )
THAT LETS EVERY AMERICAN FILL
OUT HIS OR HER TAXES ON A
POSTCARD.
>> Larry: AND TO WHOM WOULD I
BE SENDING THAT TAX POSTCARD?
IS THERE A PARTICULAR SERVICE
YOU'RE GOING TO SET UP TO HANDLE
THIS COUNTRY'S INTERNAL
REVENUES?
( LAUGHTER )
GOOD THING THERE'S A
10-SECOND RULE ON BUILDING
BLOWS.
THERE WE GO.
EVERYTHING'S THE SAME.
WHAT ELSE DID COLONEL NOT THINK
IT THROUGH HAVE TO SAY?
>> IT IS TIME TO RECLAIM THE
CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES
>> Larry: RECLAIM
THE CONSTITUTION?
HE THINKS JUST BECAUSE OBAMA
IS A BROTHER HE STOLE THE
CONSTITUTION FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE?
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
HE'S NOT THE BLACK NICHOLAS
CAGE.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
IT'S NOT FAIR.
ALL RIGHT, OKAY.
ENOUGH OF CRUZ.
YOU KNOW, THE PEOPLE WHO REALLY
INTEREST ME ARE THE STUDENTS IN
THE CROWD AT LIBERTY UNIVERSITY.
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN FIND THE
MINORITIES AND SEE HOW THEY'RE
REACTING TO THE SPEECH.
LET ME GET OUT MY TRUSTY NIGHTLY
SHOW MINORITY FINDER.
I HAVE TO BE CAREFUL WITH
THIS TECHNOLOGY.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU DON'T WANT
SOMETHING CALLED THE MINORITY
FINDER TO WIND UP IN THE WRONG
HANDS.
IT'S BUILT FOR OCCASIONS LIKE
THIS.
IT'S PERFECT.
LET'S JUST SEE.
PULL THIS OUT.
PULL UP THE SPEECH AGAIN, PULL
UP THE-- OH, OKAY.
OH, THERE'S-- THEY LOOK PRETTY
BORED.
LET'S SEE, THOSE GIRLS -- THOSE
GIRLS THERE AREN'T INTO IT.
HERE'S ONE.
IS IT-- IS THAT GUY READING A
BOOK?
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
ENHANCE THAT, MINORITY FINDER.
ENHANCE IT.
GOOD.
HOW ABOUT THESE PEOPLE?
ARE THEY TEXTING EACHOTHER?
OKAY, YOU CAN INTERPRET THE
COMMUNIQUES.
THIS IS GOOD. "NEW KENDRICK IS
FIRE." "I DIDN'T LISTEN TO IT
BECAUSE I GO TO LIBERTY
UNIVERSITY."
"OH, RIGHT, ME, TOO, I FORGOT."
OKAY.
OH, AND CHECK OUT THESE BLACK
PEOPLE WHO MIDSPEECH ARE JUST
STRAIGHT UP LEAVING.
( LAUGHTER )
YEAH, YEAH, WE GOT IT.
NOW LET'S GET OUT OF HERE AND
WATCH THE SEASON FINALE OF
"EMPIRE."
LET'S GO.
BUT THE BIGGEST TAKEAWAY OF THE
SPEECH WAS CRUZ' CODED LANGUAGE
ABOUT HOW HE SEES THE FUTURE OF
THE COUNTRY.
>> I WANT TO TALK TO YOU THIS
MORNING ABOUT REIGNITING THE
PROMISE OF AMERICA.
AS WE COME TOGETHER TO RECLAIM
THE PROMISE OF AMERICA, WE WILL
GET BACK AND RESTORE THAT
SHINING CITY ON A HILL THAT IS
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> Larry: I GET IT.
I GET IT.
IN ORDER TO GO FORWARD, YOU HAVE
TO GO BACK, RIGHT?
RECLAIM, RESTORE, REIGNITE.
SO WHAT YOU'RE REALLY SAYING IS
SOMEBODY STOLE YOUR COUNTRY.
BLACK GUY DID IT, RIGHT?
BLACKLASH AT ITS FINEST.